♪
>> I MEAN THIS IS INCREDIBLY
HIGH STAKES FOR EVERYBODY
INVOLVED AT THIS POINT.
>> THIS IS TRULY UNCHARTED
TERRITORY.
>> I FEEL LIKE WE ARE
WATCHING VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
BEST FANTASY PLAY OUT IN
REALTIME.
>> THIS IS NOT ONLY
IMPEACHABLE, IT'S NOT ONLY
WRONG.
IT COULD WELL BE A CRIME.
AND IF IT'S NOT A CRIME, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HELL IS.
>> Juan: A NEW FIRESTORM OUT
OF WASHINGTON.
A WHISTLEBLOWER REPORTEDLY
SAYS THE PRESIDENT MADE A
PROMISE TO A FOREIGN LEADER
THAT WAS CONCERNING.
AND THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" REPORTING TODAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP PRESSURED
THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE
ABOUT 8 TIMES TO INVESTIGATE
JOE BIDEN'S SON.
THE JOURNAL ALSO REPORTING
THE SOURCE DOESN'T BELIEVE
TRUMP OFFERED ANY QUID PRO
QUO FOR THAT COOPERATION.
BUT DEMOCRATS ARE DEMANDING
MORE INFORMATION.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE IS
FIRING BACK.
>> A PARTISAN WHISTLE
BLOWER.
IT'S JUST ANOTHER POLITICAL
HACK JOB.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT I
DISCUSS BUT IT I WILL SAY
THIS.
SOMEBODY OUGHT TO LOOK INTO
JOE BIDEN'S STATEMENT
BECAUSE IT WAS DISGRACEFUL.
HAVE YOU HAD A VERY BAD WEEK
AND THIS WILL BE BETTER THAN
ALL OF THEM.
THIS IS ANOTHER ONE.
SO KEEP PLAYING IT UP
BECAUSE YOU ARE GOING TO
LOOK REALLY BAD WHEN IT
FALLS I GUESS I'M ABOUT 22-0
AND I WILL KEEP IT THAT WAY.
>> Juan: JOE BIDEN JUST
RESPONDING HE SAID PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S CLAIM HAVE NO
CREDIBILITY.
JESSE, LET ME GO TO YOU.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THIS IS A
POLITICAL HACK JOB.
WHAT YOU CAN SEE IS THAT IN
FACT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
OF THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE FELT THAT HE
WAS OBLIGATED TO PASS THIS
INFORMATION TO CONGRESS THEN
OF COURSE THEY WENT TO A
LAWYER WHO WENT TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SAID
WE ARE NOT SURE THIS IS
URGENT IT WASN'T A LEAK.
IT WASN'T DONE
IRRESPONSIBLY.
IT WENT THROUGH APPROPRIATE
CHANNELS.
NOW PEOPLE ARE RAISING REAL
CONCERNS THAT THERE WAS A
QUID PRO-QUO.
>> Jesse: THE COUP IS GOING
THROUGH APPROPRIATE CHANNELS
NOW, JUAN?
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE
ANOTHER BOMBSHELL WIND UP IN
THE GARBAGE HEAP.
LET ME BREAK IT ALL DOWN.
>> Juan: OKAY.
>> Jesse: THIS IS A TIME JOE
BIDEN'S SON GETS NO SHOW
SWEETHEART DEAL AT YOU
RAINYIAN COMPANY
UKINYIAN COMPANY
UKRAYIAN COMPANY
UKRAINAN COMPANY
UKRAINIA COMPANY
UKRAINIANCOMPANY
UKRAINIAN CMPANY
UKRAINIAN COMANY
UKRAINIAN COMPAY
UKRAINIAN COMPANY VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THIS WHOLE
COMPANY FALLS APART BECAUSE
IT'S CORRUPT AND THEY START
BEING INVESTIGATED BY THE
UKRAINIANS.
JOE BIDEN GOES OVER THERE
AND TELLS UKRAINIANS FIRE
THE GUY INVESTIGATING MY
SON'S COMPANY OR ELSE YOU
ARE NOT GETTING YOUR
BILLION-DOLLAR LOAN.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DO?
THEY FIRE THE GUY
INVESTIGATING HIS SON AND
THEY GET THE BILLION-DOLLAR
LOAN.
AND THEN A YEAR LATER, THE
UKRAINIANS PASS ALL THE
MANAFORT DIRT TO THE
DEMOCRAT NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
GETS MANAFORT FIRED AND HELP
STARTS UP THE WHOLE RUSSIA
COLLUSION THING.
TRUMP IS ACCUSED OF BEING A
COLLUDER.
WAIT A SECOND.
WHY AM I BEING ACCUSED OF
THIS.
HEY UKRAINIANS CAN YOU LOOK
INTO THIS SKETCHY LITTLE
DEAL HERE?
HE HAD COMPLETE LATITUDE AS
A COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF TO ASK
A FOREIGN COUNTRY TO
INVESTIGATE SOME CORRUPTION.
WE DO IT WITH CHINESE.
WE DO IT TO MEXICANS ALL THE
TIME.
FOR SOME SNAKE WHO I DON'T
EVEN TRUST TO BLOW THE
WHISTLE IS JUST INSURANCE
POLICY 20.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS TO DEAL
WITH THIS STUFF CONSTANTLY.
IT'S GOING TO FALL APART
AGAIN.
EVERYTHING HE IS BEING
ACCUSE YOU HAD OF IS EXACT
SAME THING HILLARY AND BIDEN
WERE GUILTY OF.
>> I WOULD JUST SAY QUICKLY
THAT THIS HAS BEEN LOOKED AT
BY MAJOR NEWS ORGANIZATIONS.
>> Jesse: KIND OF LIKE THE
RUSSIA HOAX, RIGHT, JUAN?
>> Juan: EXCUSE ME.
JOE BIDEN'S SON AND WHOLE
BUSINESS HAD COLLAPSED MORE
THAN A YEAR BEFORE JOE BIDEN
EVER HAD ANYTHING TO SAY TO
THE UKRAINIANS.
>> Jesse: HE WAS STILL THERE
AT THE TIME WHEN BIDEN WENT
OVER THERE.
>> Juan: NO WAS NOT.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Jesse: HE TOOK THE MONEY
AND RAN THEN, JUAN.
ON THE WAY HE WAS STILL ON
THE HOOK FOR AN
INVESTIGATION.
>> Juan: I'M SURE THE
PRESIDENT IS PLEASED WITH
YOUR PRESENTATION CAN YOU
STOP NOW.
>> Jesse: IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
IT'S ABOUT THE TRUTH, JUAN.
>> Juan: IF I WAS TO GET TO
THE MOST POWERFUL PART OF
THIS ALLEGATION IT WOULD BE
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
EXTORBERTING A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT FOR I THINK IT
WAS $250 MILLION IN DEFENSE
AID IN EXCHANGE FOR GOING
ARE A A POLITICAL OPPONENT
JOE BIDEN.
>> EXCEPT THE LATEST REPORT
WE HAVE DOESN'T SAY THAT THE
QUID PRO QUO PART OF THIS
EQUATION IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PARTS OF THIS
STORY.
AND THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" STORY TONIGHT SAYS
THAT ACCORDING TO THEIR
FINDING THERE WAS TO QUID
PRO QUO.
THAT THE PRESIDENT ASKED,
THEY SAID 8 TIMES.
AND CAN'T YOU SEE HIM 8
TIMES.
YOU REALLY OUGHT TO LOOK
INTO THIS.
DID YOU HEAR ME?
YOU REALLY OUGHT TO LOOK
INTO THIS BIDEN STORY FOR
THE REASONS JESSE POINTS OUT
HE SEES IT GOING ALL THE WAY
BACK TO IT BEGINNING YOU OF
THIS RUSH PROBE.
ACCORDING TO THIS REPORT AT
LEAST.
I WANT TO GETTING NEW
OFFERINGS THIS EVERY SEVERAL
HOURS.
HERE IS WHERE IT SANDS RIGHT
NOW ACCORDING TO THE LATEST
JOURNAL REPORTING THERE WAS
NOTHING OFFERED IN RETURN
FOR THAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT JOE BIDEN'S
SITUATION AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT&T WHAT HE ACTUALLY SAID.
WHEN YOU GO BACK AND LOOK AT
THE APPEAR AND HE MADE ON
FOREIGN REGIONS HE IS
BOASTING ABOUT THE FACT THAT
HE DID HAVE A QUID PRO QUO.
HE SAID I TOLD THEM THERE IS
NO WAY YOU ARE GETTING THAT
BILLION-DOLLAR LOAN
GUARANTEE UNLESS YOU FIRE
THIS GUY.
HE WAS BOASTING ABOUT IT.
I TOLD THEM AT THIS TIME FOR
FAT.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING GETTING
WHAT YOU WANT UNLESS I GET
WHAT I WANT.
THAT'S A PRETTY CLEAR QUID
PRO QUO.
THAT'S ON TAPE AND THAT'S
JOE BIDEN TALKING ABOUT THE
SITUATION HIMSELF.
>> Juan: GREG, WHAT WE HAVE
HERE IS A SITUATION WHERE
RUDY GIULIANI LAST KNIGHT HE
SAYS WELL, NO, I NEVER ASKED
THE UKRAINIANS TO DO
ANYTHING WHEN I WENT OVER
THERE.
THEN LIKE 20 SECONDS LATER
HE SAID WELL YEAH, OF COURSE
I DID.
>> Greg: THAT'S HOUR LAWYERS
TALK.
I WASN'T TALKING ABOUT THAT
BUT SOMETHING RELATED TO
THAT.
YOU CAN HAVE THAT.
IT DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING TO
ME.
I FIND IT INTERESTING THAT
TRUMP IS THE ONLY PERSON THE
MEDIA UP APPROVES OF BEING
INVESTIGATED.
IF THE E78D IS GOING TO
IGNORE JOE BIDEN THEN HOW
DARE YOU SUGGEST IT, RIGHT?
THE FACT IT IS SO TRUMP YOU
SHOULD BE CHECK THIS GUY OUT
BECAUSE HE DOES THAT ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
HE IS ALWAYS POSING
QUESTIONS, WHY CAN'T DO YOU
THIS?
WHY CAN'T I FIRE THIS
PERSON?
I'M NOT GETTING SUCKERED
INTO THIS STORY.
EVERY DAMN BOMBSHELL BECOMES
A DEAD.
IF I REACTED TO EVERY SINGLE
STORY IN WHICH THE HAIR ISEN
FIRE HE WOULD NEED COMPLETED
RESUCCESS STATION.
THEY ACT LIKE IT'S THE
BIGGEST THING THOUGHT
PORTLAND.
WHEN IT'S IT'S NOD THEY WILL
ALL TAMP WAY THEY HIFT ON IT
AND IT FIZZES.
IT'S A BUSINESS MODEL
PREDICATED ON APOP LIP
PARTICULAR FERVOR.
I AIN'T GOING TO BUY INTO
IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT SUCKS, JUAN,
WHEN SOMETHING HAPPENS NO
ONE BELIEVES IT ANYMORE.
THIS COULD BE REAL BUT NO
ONE IS GOING TO BELIEVE IT.
HOW CAN YOU BELIEVE THE
MEDIA ON ANYTHING ANYMORE
WHEN THEY COMPLETELY
EXAGGERATE EVERYTHING.
BIDEN DOESN'T WANT THIS
STORY GOING ANYWHERE NEAR
HIM EITHER BECAUSE THIS IS
JUST GOING TO PUT HIM IN --
THIS IS GOING TO DRAG HIM
INTO IT.
>> DAY BEGAN SO, SO THEY ARE
NOT ALLOWING THE SENATE OR
THE HOUSE TO LOOK AT THIS
WHISTLE BLOWER INFORMATION.
AINSLEY: TODAY IN THIS
HOUSE.
>> Juan: NOT SO FAR.
I'M THINKING TO MYSELF IF
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT AND
THERE IS NOTHING TO THIS,
WHY DON'T THEY WANT THE
CONGRESS TO SEE IT?
>> I EXPECT IN THE COMING
DAYS YOU ARE GOING TO GET A
TRANSCRIPT OF THIS PHONE
CALL BECAUSE THIS
WHISTLEBLOWER IS NOT THE
ONLY PERSON WHO WAS PROBABLY
ON THE CALL ON OR ABOUT HAD
ACCESS TO THE TRANSCRIPT IT.
WILL BE CLEAR AS DAY EXACTLY
WHAT WAS SAID.
THAT'S HOW YOU CLEAR UP
ANYTHING THAT'S GOING ON
BECAUSE HAMSTER WHEELS,
GREG, MAKE ME NAUSEATED.
WHO ARE YOU GOING TO LISTEN
TO ADAM SCHIFF WHO GOES FROM
ZERO TO IMPEACHMENT IN A
SNEEZE.
A MAN WHO ESSENTIALLY LIED
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT
COLLUSION FOR MORE THAN TWO
YEARS.